Ja bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Andreas Scholten.
Andreas Scholten. Könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Ja natürlich. Mein Vornamen ist A-N-D-R-R-V-R-S-A-S Andreas. Mein Vornamen ist Scholten S-C-H-S-C-H-O-N-T-E-N.
Herr Scholten, wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
33 Jahre Herr Doktor.
33 Jahre. Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
18.9.1989
18.9.1989. Ok, das habe ich notiert. Herr Scholten, wie groß sind Sie?
1,75 Meter Herr Doktor.
1,75 Meter. Und wissen Sie wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja 72,3.
Formationen. Was würdest du Ihnen heute zu uns geben? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen Herr Scholten?
Herr Doktor, ich habe nach einem Monat Schmerzen. Aber seit vier Tagen habe ich Schmerzen.
Seit einem Monat haben Sie diese Schmerzen. Aber seit ein paar Tagen oder seit?
Seit vier Tagen.
Ok. Sind Sie stärker geworden?
Ja.
Ok. Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen? Könnten Sie mir zeigen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe einen Schmerz mit Kopfschmerzen. Hinterkopf immer.
Hinterkopf. Ok.
Und stellen Sie diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja. Meine linke Hand tut weh.
Und meine Schulter tut weh.
Ganzes Schulter oder nur linke Zeit?
Nur linke Zeit.
Ok. Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Langsam Herr Doktor. Langsam.
Aber seit vier Tagen stärker.
Ok. Sind sie dauerhaft oder verschwinden sie zeitweise?
Ja. Immer dauerhaft.
Ok. Herr Scholten, wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
Wobei 0 keine Schmerzen und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen bedeutet.
Ja. Für ja ist weniger. Aber jetzt sind es 7 und 8 Herr Doktor.
7 und 8 bis von 10. Ok.
Könnten Sie mir diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Brennen, Stichen, Ziehen?
Herr Doktor, Brennen und Drücken.
Brennen und Drücken. Ok. Das ist Herr Doktor.
Sehr stark.
Können Sie... Es sieht so aus, dass Sie eine starke Schmerzen haben.
Möchten Sie Schmerzmittel oder können Sie das bis zum Ende des Geschwächs aushalten?
Ja. Es wäre besser Herr Doktor.
Ok. Haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Keine Medikamente Herr Doktor.
Ja. Ich rufe die kranken Schwestern, damit sie ein Schmerzmittel bekommen Herr Scholten.
Ok.
Entschuldigung. Gibt es einen Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Vielleicht haben Sie sich am Kopf verletzt oder haben Sie etwas Schwieriges gehoben?
Nein. Ich habe keinen Kopf verletzt oder ich habe keine Nacken oder Schuhe verletzt Herr Doktor.
Aber bei mir ist meine Schmerzen verschwunden.
Es gibt eine Einschränkung mit diesen Schmerzen.
Wie bitte?
Zum Beispiel könnten Sie drehen?
Ja. Wenn ich meinen Kopf drehe, ist die Schmerzen stark.
Ok. Gibt es etwas das die Schmerzen linden?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen Herr Doktor. Aber gestern habe ich eine Wartexposition gesehen.
Wie bitte?
Wart warme Kompression.
Ok. Hat das Ihnen geholfen?
Ja. Anmischen.
Ok. Das ist auch gut zu wissen.
Haben Sie dagegen Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein.
Keine?
Und Sie haben seit einem Monat diese Schmerzen. Waren Sie deswegen beim Arzt?
Nein. Ich war nicht.
Herr Schulte, haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Nein. Ich habe keine.
Und die Schmerzen in Ihrem linken Arm ausgetragen?
Ja.
Haben Sie ein Taubheitsgefühl in Ihrem linken Arm oder irgendwo am inneren Körper?
Herr Doktor, ich habe ein linkes Arm, ein Taubheitsgefühl und ein Körper. Aber ich habe keine Schwierigkeiten meine Arme zu bewegen.
Sie haben keine Muskelschwäche?
Nein.
So weit ich verstehe.
Sehen Sie linkes oder reizende Arme?
Reizende.
Ok. Reizende.
Eine Lehmungerscheinigung haben Sie erwähnt.
Und ich würde gerne wissen, haben Sie ganz schön Hör- oder Sprachstörungen?
Sind Sie erkält?
Nicht nur ein kleines bisschen Küsten.
Herr Schulte, haben Sie sehr Hör- oder Sprachstörungen?
Nein.
Das ist auch gut zu wissen, gut zu hören.
Haben Sie Fieber, Stellfrust, Nachtschweiß oder kalten Schweiß?
Nein.
Und haben Sie Schwindel?
Oder ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Kein Schwindel.
Haben Sie auch Lichtempfindlichkeit?
Nein.
Ok.
Herr Schulte, ist Ihnen übel?
Müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Wie sieht es mit dem Stuhlgang aus?
Nein.
Ok.
Wie ist die Repetit, Herr Schulte?
Normal war es so gut, aber wegen Schmerzen habe ich seit 3 Tagen nicht gut.
Haben Sie letztes Mal ungewollt ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Ok.
Aber Sie haben keine Herzrasen oder Engelgefühl?
Nein, Herr Doktor, ich habe keine.
Ok.
Das habe ich so notiert.
Denken Sie andere Medikamente, andere Krankheiten?
Ich muss alle Wahrscheinlichkeiten denken, Herr Schulte.
Ich habe keine, Doktor.
Der Körper hat viele Zusammenhänge, vom Kopf bis Fuß.
Deswegen sollen wir danach fragen.
Ok.
Und keine Gewichtsveränderung.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich habe auch ein bisschen Repetit.
Normal war es gut, aber seit 3 Tagen habe ich nicht gut wegen Schmerzen.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen.
Ok.
Das habe ich notiert.
Gibt es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte, Herr Schulte,
zum Beispiel chronische Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck oder erhöhte Blutfettwerte?
Normalerweise leichte Kopfschmerzen seit langen Jahren.
Aber jetzt habe ich eine starke Kopf- und Nackenschmerzen.
Außerdem habe ich seit 2 Wochen Ohrensausen.
Seit 2 Wochen.
Ja.
Ok.
Ist das beiseitig oder einseitig?
Beiseitig.
Seit 3 Wochen.
Ok.
Und Sie haben auch Kopfschmerzen, aber leichte seit langem.
Sie haben es so erwähnt.
Wie können Sie diese Kopfschmerzen beschreiben?
Drücken oder in andere Charakter wie jetzige, als jetzige Kopfschmerzen?
Beiseitig drücken, Herr Doktor.
Aber ich habe keine Diagnose festgestellt.
Ich habe mir 100mg bei Bedarf nehmen gehen Kopfschmerzen ein.
Oder ist das Diagnostizier?
In der Hüte.
Sind Sie diagnostiziert?
Ich meine die Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe keine Diagnose festgestellt.
Aber es wäre besser, wenn Sie solche Beschwerden haben, sofort oder so schnell
wie möglich einen Hausarzt oder Ihren Hausarzt besuchen.
Ja.
Ohne astliche Art Medikamente einzunehmen, könnte es für Ihre Gesundheit schädlich
sein.
Aber meine Kollegin Dr.
Dogan hat mir diese gesagt.
Dann nehme ich 400mg an.
Wenn ein Arzt Sie verschrieben hat oder empfohlen hat.
Okay, kein Problem.
Ja, noch etwas?
Haben Sie Herr Schulter eine andere Krankheit?
Nein, nein.
Wurde Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja.
Herr Doktor, mit 15 Jahren ist meine Unterarmbrotchen und bei mir wurde Metallfixation durchgeführt.
Nach dem einen Jahr wurde bei mir wieder Metallfixation extraktiver.
Rechts oder links?
Rechts.
Links.
War die Operamkommission unslos?
Nein, nein.
Keine Komplikation.
Außer Ibuprofen nehmen Sie Regelmäßig oder Baybedarf Medikamente ein?
Baybedarf, Herr Doktor.
Außer Ibuprofen?
Nein.
Sie haben keine Medikamentallergie, Sie haben noch andere Allergie?
Ja, ich habe Ht-Polyne Allergie, aber mit Eigenbluttherapie behandelt wurde bei mir.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Okay, gut zu hören.
Haben Sie ein Verbrechen?
Nein.
Herr Scholter, darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben?
Ja, Herr Doktor, seit fünf Jahren rauche ich vier Zigaretten täglich.
Seit fünf Jahren?
Ja.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Scholter?
Ja, natürlich, Herr Doktor.
Zwei oder drei Gläser Wein anwenden, trinke ich seit 15 Jahren.
Also muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben, Herr Scholter?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Herr Scholter, treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, leider.
Nein, nein, kein Sport.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder zu Hause?
Ja, natürlich, ich habe Stress, aber keine Probleme.
Sie können damit umgehen?
Ja, ja, ja.
So, was ich verstehe.
Okay.
Wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen, natürlich sind wir für Sie hier, für Sie da.
Okay, sind Ihre Eltern gesund, Herr Scholter?
Leider, mein Vater ist verstorben, Herr Doktor.
Es tut mir leid, woran ist er verstorben?
An Herzinfarkt, Herr Doktor.
Wie alt war er?
Er war 55, vor zwei Jahren.
55, okay, es tut mir leid.
Aber Herzkrankheit, oder?
Je nach bisherigen Angaben gehe ich nicht davon aus, dass Sie einen Herzinfarkt haben.
Aber ich werde auch das überprüfen.
Okay?
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Okay, wie ist Ihre Mutter?
Was ist mit Ihrer Mutter?
Meine Mutter leidet an Blut, Herr Doktor.
Sie ist am Leben.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Nein, keine Geschwister.
Ja, was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Scholter?
Das ist wichtig zu wissen.
Oder arbeiten Sie im Büro oder arbeiten Sie am Computer?
Diese Informationen sind für mich wichtig, eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Ja, ich arbeite im Büro mit dem Computer, Herr Doktor.
Ich arbeite als Anwohner im Meldamt.
Ein Anwohner, beim Meldamt.
Und im Büro vor dem Computer.
Ja.
Wie viele Stunden arbeiten Sie pro Tag?
Ja, natürlich sechs, sieben Stunden, Herr Doktor.
Sechs oder sieben Stunden?
Ja, leider.
Okay, Herr Scholter.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Keine Kinder?
Okay.
Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld.
Laut Ihren Beschwerden, Herr Scholter, habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Muskelverspannung
im Nackenbereich.
Ist das gefährlich?
Ich erkläre.
Das kann mit Ihrer Fehlkörperhaltung oder Überbelastung oder einem Verschleiß auftreten.
Sie können die Ursachen dafür sein.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Deswegen müssen wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, um das zu bestätigen.
Zunächst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach nehme ich Blut für das Labor ab.
Und ich werde eine EKG schreiben, um mögliche Herzursache auszuschließen.
Weil Sie haben auch manche Sorgen.
Sie haben sich Sorgen auch.
Und wie gesagt, mit allen Ergebnissen.
Und ich werde auch röntgen.
Sobald Ihre Ergebnisse und Befunde vorliegen, besuche ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt.
Danach komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es weitergeht.
Haben Sie Fragen oder gibt es noch etwas, das Sie hinzufügen möchten?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich habe gefragt.
Ist es gefährlich?
Und warum habe ich meine Muskelverspannung?
Ja, ich habe das erklärt.
Vielleicht arbeiten Sie zu viel.
6 oder 7 Stunden pro Tag im Büro und immer vor dem Computer.
Vielleicht arbeiten Sie z.B. in einem verstellbaren Tisch oder Stuhl oder unverstellbare.
Unverstellbare.
Oder nutzen Sie ein ergonomisches Maus.
Ja.
Wir wissen nicht Ihre Beschwerden.
Deswegen können Ihre Beschwerden eine Ursache davon sein.
Aber wir brauchen wahrscheinlich keine Operation.
Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Wir können diese Krankheit durch anpassende Medikamente behandeln.
Ok, vielen Dank Herr Doktor.
Und warten Sie auf mich.
Können Sie eine Suche machen?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Ich mache es, Herr Doktor.
Entschuldigung, Kling Kling.
Hallo, ich bin Frau Müller aus dem Labor.
Herr Kadasch, der Trombositentwert ist 39.000 pro Mikroliter.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Oberart weiterleiten?
Ich kann gerne das machen.
Aber brauche ich die Wiederholung des Namens Kadasch.
Könnten Sie das wiederholen?
Ja, K-A-D-A-S-C-H wie Schule.
Herr Kadasch, ok, das mache ich.
Danke.
Tschüss, auf Wiederhören.
Herr Doan, mein Name ist Aydis und Sie sind willkommen.
Danke, Herr Oberarzt.
Wie geht es Ihnen, Herr Doan?
Ja, mir geht es gut.
Vielen Dank.
Bei mir auch.
Woher kommen Sie, Herr Doan?
Herr Oberarzt, ich komme aus der Türkei.
Ich bin 41 Jahre alt und lebe seit etwas mehr als 2,5 Jahren in Deutschland.
Verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Seitdem wohne ich mit meiner Frau und meinen zwei Söhnen in Simmergatt in der Eiferregion.
Da näher?
Ja, wir sind am Grenze.
Fast jeden Tag sind wir auch in Belgien.
Ok, wann haben Sie in Deutschland 2,5 Jahre lang gemacht?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich mit dem Deutsch lernen erst hier nach meiner Ankunft in Deutschland angefangen.
Seitdem lerne ich intensiv Deutsch.
Ich habe von 0 bis 32 Jahre lang Deutsch gelernt in der Archen Sprachakademie.
Danach habe ich an der RWTH einen C1-Kurs gemacht.
Danach habe ich wieder bei der Sprachakademie einen 6-monatigen Fachsprachprüfungskurs gemacht.
Dann bin ich hier für die Sprachprüfung.
Ok, die Sprachen sind sehr gut.
Was haben Sie in der Türkei als Arzt gemacht?
Ja, meine Medizinstudium habe ich 2009 an der Universität Istanbul-Cerapba geschlossen.
Danach habe ich als praktischer Arzt in der Notaufnahme und als Familienarzt gearbeitet.
Dann habe ich 2 Jahre lang in der Pathologieabteilung und 4 Jahre lang in der Innermedizinabteilung weiter Bildungen gemacht.
Im Jahr 2017 musste ich aus politischen Gründen meine Schitelle an der Universität verlassen.
Danach bis 2023 habe ich als Praktischer Arzt in der Notaufnahme gearbeitet.
Weil ich die Lebensbedingungen in der Türkei als unsicher und schwierig empfinde,
habe ich mich entschieden nach Deutschland zu kommen.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass ich meinen Beruf hier gut ausüben kann.
Mein Ziel in Deutschland ist es, meine bisherigen Kenntnisse zu erkennen und die notwendigen Weiterbildungen zu absolvieren.
Dann darf ich als Hausarzt arbeiten.
Sie haben einen guten Plan. Ich hoffe, dass Sie es schaffen können.
Natürlich bin ich aufmerksam, dass ich nicht in einer einfachen Situation mit 40 Jahren solche Ziele erfüllen kann.
Aber ich habe keine Chance ohne zu versuchen.
Ok. Haben Sie aus dem Labor einen Anruf bekommen?
Herr Oberntz, ich muss Ihnen diese Werte teilen.
Diese Werte sind stark erniedrigt.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, dass Herr Kadaj einen Thrombocytinzahl von 39.000 pro Mikroliter hat.
Dieser Wert ist stark erniedrigt und spürt eine Thrombocytopenie.
Thrombocytopenien zahlen zwischen 150.000 und 450.000 pro Mikroliter.
Ok. Können wir diesen Patienten operieren?
Ich habe diesen Patienten nicht gesehen.
Ich habe nur diesen Wert.
Deswegen kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Aber als Allgemeine Informationen dürfen wir diesen Patienten nicht operieren.
Aber bei einer Notoperation können wir unter manchen Voransetzungen operieren.
Ich denke, dass es auch von der Operation abhängt.
Wir würden Thrombocytin konzentriert geben.
Wenn die Wert von 50.000 pro Mikroliter ist, können wir diesen Patienten operieren.
Aber wie gesagt, es hängt von der Operation ab.
Ok.
Ich habe hier eine kurze Antwort.
Ich habe etwas nicht gesehen, was ich gesagt habe.
Ich habe nur gesagt, dass es nicht gut ist.
Wir können den Patienten mit konzentriert operieren.
Wir können den Patienten mit Konzentriert operieren.
Es ist wichtig, dass die Patienten nicht mit Konzentriert operieren.
Ok.
Ich habe nur einen Satz.
Ich habe heute Herrn Andreas Scholten aufgenommen.
Er ist 33 Jahre alt, geboren am 18.9.1989 und er ist 1,75 Meter groß und wiegt 72,3 Kilogramm.
Er kam heute zu uns wegen seit 4 Tagen bestehender linkseitiger Schmerzen im Nackenbereich und im Hinterkopf.
Laut der Aussage der Patienten sind die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in den linken Arm und in die linke Schulter ausgetragen werden.
Nach Angaben der Patienten sind die Schmerzen brennend und drücken und progredieren.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 7 bis 8 von 10 auf der NRS.
Deswegen musste ich das Gespräch unterbrechen um eine Schmerzmitte zu geben.
Die Schmerzen verschlimmern sich bei Bewegung und während sie sich bei Wärmekissen besser machen.
Er berichtet, dass er seit einem Monat ähnliche Beschwerden hatte.
Das war leichter als jetzige Schmerzen.
Sie wurden im Laufe der Zeit stärker geworden.
Er war nicht beim Arzt und nimmt dagegen keine Medikamente.
Begleitend klagt er über Taubheitsgefühl und Kriben im linken Arm.
Vegetative anamnestisch ergaben sich in Appetanz und schmerzbedingte Dysomnie.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er seit Langem an leichten Kopfschmerzen und seit zwei Wochen an beidseitigem Tinnitus.
Er nimmt bei Bedarf gegen Kopfschmerzen 400 mg Ibuprofen ein.
Er hatte Polenallergie, die damals durch eigene Bluttherapie behandelt wurde.
Er raucht seit fünf Jahren vier Zigaretten.
Er trinkt zwei, drei Gläser Wein pro Woche.
Er treibt keinen regelmäßigen Sport.
Die Familienanamnese ergab ein Myokardinfarkt bei dem Vater und eine arterielle Hypertonie bei der Mutter.
Sozialanamnistisch...
Wie alt ist sein Vater?
Als er verstorben war, war er 55 Jahre alt.
Er arbeitet im Büro täglich sechs und sieben Stunden täglich.
Er ist Rechtshänder und arbeitet tagsüber vor dem Computer.
Nach den anamnestischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf eine funktionelle Halswirbelsäule-Syndrom.
Dafür sprechen Nacken und...
Was bedeutet funktionelle?
Funktionelle bedeutet...
Die Halswirbelsäule-Syndrom können auch funktionelle oder degenerative oder entzündliche auftreten.
Funktionelle Halswirbelsäule bedeutet, keine entzündliche oder pathologische Knochen oder Gelenke befinden.
Aufgetretenes Halswirbelsäule-Syndrom kann wegen Fehlhaltung oder Überlastung, wegen wiederholter überlastender Bewegungen auftreten.
Okay, haben Sie Differenzialdiagnostik?
Ja, natürlich. Differenzialdiagnose.
Ja, ich habe auch zwei Differenzialdiagnose.
Differenzialdiagnostik, kommen ein auch vegetatives Halswirbelsäule-Syndrom und auch Bandscheibenvorfall, HWS-Bandscheibenvorfall, in Betracht.
Obwohl oder auch wenn der Patient jung ist, muss ich diese zwei Wahrscheinlichkeiten ausschließen.
Deswegen denke ich als Differenzialdiagnostik beide Krankheiten.
Okay, beide. Okay, was würden Sie als Differenzdiagnostik machen?
Um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich natürlich zuerst den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen und außerdem sollte eine EKG geschrieben werden, um mögliche Herzursache auszuschließen.
Der Patient hat Risikofaktoren wie familiäre Belastung und in den linken Arm aus zitralen Schmerzen.
Deswegen muss ich diese Wahrscheinlichkeit ausschließen.
Und ich werde auch Röntgen, zellikale Röntgen auf Namen veranlassen. Zwei Erbenen.
Gegebenenfalls vielleicht MRT veranlassen oder können kann veranlassen werden.
Ja, sie haben als Differenzialdiagnose Bandscheibenvorfall. Deswegen müssen wir MRT veranlassen.
Okay, wenn Sie Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, wie würden Sie den Patienten behandeln?
Ich würde diesen Patienten ambulant behandeln. Als Initialtherapie würde ich Analgetikum und Muskelrelexanten verordnen.
Das ist sehr wichtig, eine Patientenschulung, wie Körperhaltung, ergonomische Körperhaltung und Arbeitsumfeld.
Das ist sehr wichtig für diese Patienten. Und Physiotherapie, Krankengymnastik würde ich empfehlen für ihn.
Ja, in diesem Fall ist Krankengymnastik wichtig.
Für akute Beschwerden soll ich zuerst diese Schmerzen linden und diese Muskelverspannung entspannen.
Deswegen soll ich zuerst Analgetikum und Muskelrelexanten verordnen.
Okay, das ist gut. Vielen Dank. Sie können uns morgen eine E-Mail verabschieden.
Du hast die Diagnose Bandscheibenvorfall gesagt. Das ist nicht möglich. Was ist das für eine Artistisch-Fachbegriff?
Diskus prolapsus.
Diskus prolapsus in Halsbereich. Und auch vegetativ Diskus prolapsus. Was heißt das? Ich weiß es nicht.
Was war das erste Anzeige?
Das ist nicht vegetativ, das ist degenerativ.
Okay, das ist nicht vegetativ.
So ist es.
Ich habe es schon gehört.
Du hast es gesagt, aber ich habe es auch gehört.
Ich habe es auch gehört.
Du bist wie ein Radar, ich habe es auch gehört. Aber ich habe es gehört. Du hast es gesagt, degenerativ zu sagen.
Die Kulinearen sind ein bisschen degenerativ.
Ich habe es auch gehört.
Du hast es auch gehört.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Akutez, Koronar, Zendron, zwei Basis-Tipps gehen würde.
Aber ist Muscliferspannung nicht die gleiche Sache?
Nein, das ist nicht die gleiche Sache.
Normalerweise ist es eine andere Sache.
Muscliferspannung ist anders, Funktionelle, Halbfieber, Zäure, Endrom sind anders.
Die beiden sind anders.
Wenn du mir die beiden anstehend sagst, kann ich sie nicht anstehend sagen.
Die Pathologie ist eine Sache.
Die Kastkasse sind in der Kastkasse geschlossen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Physiotherapie oder Physik-Tatabschülle gibt.
Orthopädie.
Die Mechanismen sind in der Kastkasse geschlossen.
Die Kriben, die die Peripherenkabeln geschlossen haben.
Ich weiß nicht.
Herr, du hattest eine Mausarm und eine andere Sache.
Aber hier muss man sich auf die Erklärung anzeigen.
Du hast auch Stress in der Arbeitszeit.
In der Familie.
Das Beste ist, dass du das sagen kannst.
Wenn du das EKG sagst, dann ist es nicht so wichtig.
Das ist ein Routine.
Das ist ein Routine-Messing.
Das ist ein EKG, das die einzelnen Patienten machen.
Ich kann das immer sehen, aber das ist ein riskanter Routine.
Ich habe etwas gehört.
In der Muskelferschpanuk gibt es nur die Muskelkastengel.
In der Muskelferschpanuk sind die Muskeln zwischen den Kasten geschlossen.
Und die Kastkasse ist die eine der beiden.
In der Muskelferschpanuk sind nur die Kasten geschlossen.
Aber man muss sich das beachten.
Das ist ein Routine-Messing.
Wenn C5 und C6 unter uns sind, wird es leichter.
Die beiden sind anders.
Das ist ein technischer Detail.
Das ist ein Frage.
Das war ein Thema.
Wie man sich in einer Simulation unter und oben beitragen kann.
Soll ich das noch mal lesen?
1-2 Ober.
Und die unteren sind mit und unter.
Was ist das obere Halswirbel-Säule-Syndrom?
Und das mittlere und untere?
Mittlere oder untere.
Halswirbel-Säule-Syndrom.
Obers Halswirbel-Säule-Syndrom.
Wenn Halswirbelkörper 1. und 2. betroffen sind,
schmerzen Strahlen in den Kopf auf.
Die Ahr und die Bauchstange.
Mittleres und unteres Halswirbel-Säule-Syndrom.
Wenn die Halswirbelkörper 3. und 7. betroffen sind,
schmerzen Strahlen in die Schultern und Arme aus.
Warum hast du uns zurückgezogen?
Meine Noten sind auf Racks.
Ist das so?
Die Dialognoten?
Meine Noten sind auf Racks.
Das kann sein.
Cetin, ich frage dich ein paar Erfahrungen aus meinen Sachen.
Okay.
Wie ist das, dass die Nerven nicht zu diesem Patienten entnehmen?
Bei ihrem Fall brauchen wir nicht Nervenwasser zu entnehmen.
Die arabischen Freunde haben es so geschrieben.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Wir warten erst auf die Blutentzüge und die Diagnostik des Angehörigen.
Dann geben wir ihnen Bescheid, falls wir andere Maßnahmen brauchen.
So eine Anklage.
Was machen wir bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Wie machen wir eine Physikmahne?
Zuerst ist es wichtig,
die neurologischen Symptome auszuschließen,
wie Sensibilitätsstörungen, Reflexunterzuchung und Muskelkraft überprüfen.
Ein anderes Thema.
Bewegungen, Augen und Hören.
Neurologie, Hörung und Augen.
Ich höre ihr Herz und ihr Lungen ab.
Du hast das Akutkornersendom gedacht.
Das ist so ein Kalkalk-Synonym.
Was ist eine Halssonographie?
Damit können wir die Organe im Hals, wie Schilderose, Nebenschilderose,
auch die Gefäße über kontrollieren.
Ich höre auch.
Das ist überprüfen.
Die Kandiaats, Lymphknoten, die Üsten, 10,9 und die Urteil.
Die Kisten und Lymphknoten werden mit Turoide ausgedacht.
Eine weitere Frage.
Vielleicht gibt es ein paar Theorien, aber die werden nicht gefragt.
Was ist eine Halssonographie?
Damit können wir die Gefäße überprüfen.
Wie schnell das Blut fließt.
Ich höre auch.
Die Kombination aus der Bildung der Halsgefäße und der Überprüfung der Blutflüssgeschwindigkeit
heißt Halsdublexonographie.
Die Kombination aus der Bildung der Halsgefäße
die Dämmer auch stetig überprüfen.
Und die Überprüfung der Blutflüssgeschwindigkeit.
Die beiden sind zusammen.
Das ist der Änd flip und Tio Perizzone.
Tio Perizzone ist die Tizanidine Baklophen.
Baklofen, Metakarbomal, Tisanidin, diese Gruppe können die Skaletmuskeln und Spanen.
Tisanidin, Tisanidin, Tisanidin, Baklofen, Metakarbomal, Tisanidin, Baklofen, Metakarbomal.
Das muss man nicht mit dem Begriff bezeichnen.
Sie sind mit Glattmuskeln ausgebildet.
Deswegen sind sie mit Han-Urolithiasis ausgebildet.
Die Erleichterung ist Butyl-Sucopalamin.
So ist es gesungen.
Ich habe die Erleichterung von Butyl-Sucopalamin in Erleichterung.
Ist das Butyl-Sucopalamin?
Ja, das ist Butyl-Sucopalamin.
Das ist Antispasmotikum.
Antispasmotikum oder Spasmolytikum.
Antispasmotikum.
Das ist Tisanidin, Baklofen.
Das ist Muskelspan.
Muskelrelaxantien.
Was sind Muskelrelaxantien?
Was ist Muskelrelaxantien?
Die Muskelrelaxation der Medikamente ist die Stichwurz des Muskels.
Eine weitere Frage.
Welche Massnahme ist bei diesem Patienten sehr wichtig?
Das ist die Antwort.
Das ist in der Saison, weil die Kälte schmerzt.
Die Frau hat gefragt, ob die Kälte schmerzt.
Sie haben in der Saison gefragt.
Welche Massnahme ist bei diesem Patienten sehr wichtig?
Das ist die Antwort.
Was öffnest du für einen Patienten außer der Medikament?
Der Medikament.
Also außer der Medikament.
Welche Massnahme ist bei diesem Patienten sehr wichtig?
Die Massnahme ist sehr wichtig.
Die Körperhaltung ist wichtig.
Die ergonomische Körperhaltung ist wichtig.
Die Abweichung ist wichtig.
Die Wärmetherapie ist auch wichtig.
Die Sitze sind auch lange zu vermeiden.
Das ist die Krankmeldung und die Krankengymnastik.
Können Sie etwas sagen?
Wie?
Ich habe es gesagt, dass die Luft schwächer ist.
Können wir die Affion-Kaplichalen öffnen?
Ja, das wäre gut.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich bin ein Kanaianjaram.
Welche Massnahmen ist bei diesem Patienten sehr wichtig?
Pürüfer hat mich diese Frage an die Ende der Teil 3 gefragt.
Hätte du mir das nicht gesagt, hätte ich gesagt, dass die Krankschreiben,
was du gesagt hast, oder was sie wollen, EKG ist.
Was muss ich von den Massnahmen hier verstehen?
Kann ich auf der Bik?
Kann ich auf die Räder gehen?
Ich war vorher in den Sport-Salon.
Ich habe die Gewicht.
Kann ich arbeiten?
Die alles in die Massnahmen.
Ja, aber du hast gerade EKG gesagt.
Aber EKG zu nehmen ist ein Problem.
Wer ist die Massnahme?
Ich bin der erste Patient.
Ist die Antwort EKG?
Die Frage ist so.
Ich lese die Noten.
Okay.
Das kann auch sein.
Das ist eine Frage.
Entschuldigung.
Du kannst die Masnahme als Übungssprache beantworten.
Wenn du die Frage der Diagnose anstatt der Therapie anstatt der Therapie,
kannst du die Frage der Physiotherapie beantworten.
Ich habe auch den Chef GPT gefragt.
Er hat drei Wörter.
Der erste ist Önleim, der zweite ist Tätbir.
Der dritte ist Übungssprache.
Sie haben die drei auch beantwortet.
Das ist der Grund für unsere Wünsche.
Die Masnahme ist eine Handlung, die Sua Diagnostik, Therapie und die Prävention durchgeführt wird.
Also alles in den Hirn, die Tätigung, die Tätigkeit, die Önleim.
Der Sound ist weg, Dr. Ibrahim.
Ist er wieder her?
Es hat gerade einen Geruch, Dr. Ibrahim.
Okay, ich schaue es wieder.
Die Masnahme ist eine Handlung, die Tätigung, die Sua Diagnostik, die Tätigkeit, die Prävention.
Es ist alles drin, Dr. Ibrahim.
Das ist richtig.
Also, wenn es um die Medikamente geht, dann geht es um die Medikamente, wenn es um die Töne geht, dann geht es um die Töne und die Maßnahmen.
Jetzt gibt es noch eine Frage.
Das hat Oberast gefragt.
Wie soll man den Patienten erzählen?
Was ist Lumbar Funktion?
Du solltest den Patienten erzählen.
Mit einer Miethilfe von einer Hochnad zwischen der Ländenwirbelkörper 3 und 4 einführen und unter welchen Fällen?
Meningitis?
Das ist ein Genchast.
Nein, nein. Ich meine welchen Fällen.
Ich wollte das Wort Zart, Patman, Schicht, das heißt.
Ich weiß nicht Almanisch.
Ich...
Wir werden das von dort nehmen.
Jetzt hast du die Anweisungen sehr gut gemacht.
Es ist ein Zuchung bei der via Rückenmarksphalysikkeit.
Also, das Wort...
Rückenmarksphalysikkeit, ja.
Bei der via Rückenmarksphalysikkeit entnehmen um krankenheiten aus Schilissen.
Also, 3-4% von der Länge sind nicht so langweilig.
Das ist mir nicht zu sagen.
Ich sage das für den Patienten.
Wir werden ihren Flüssen...
Du hast es gesagt.
Ja, ja.
Oberast hat das Wort mit der Desinfektion befürworten.
Okay, ich werde das sagen.
Ich kann es von der Czech-Cipita sprechen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel ich weiß.
Die Valponction ist ein diagnostisches Verfahren, bei dem Likoserbrosypinalis aus dem subarachnoidal Raum der Lendenwirbelsohle entnommen wird, dem ich.
Die Wörter sind sehr komplex.
Ich habe die Wörter etwas einfacher gemacht.
Es ist eine Untersuchung bei der wir Rückenmarksphalysikkeit entnehmen, um krankenheiten aus Schilissen, um eine Diagnose festzustellen.
Likoserbrosypinalis?
Das ist nicht nötig.
Das ist ein Sprachwort, das in Latin auch nicht nötig ist.
Das kann auch gesagt werden.
Rückenmarksphalysikkeit.
Das kann man mehr oft benutzen.
Likoserbrosypinalis.
Sie haben etwas sehr interessantes gefragt.
Sie sagen Funktionelle Halswirbelsohle, also Syndrom.
Was hat Oberast gefragt?
Was ist das Syndrom?
Das ist ein Symptomkombination.
Das ist eine Kombination der Symptome, die der Patient oder die Patientin hat.
So ist es.
Kommen wir los.
Ich lese auch.
Du sagst es aber.
Ein Syndrom ist eine Kombination von verschiedenen Krankheitszeichen, Symptomen, die gleichzeitig und gemeinsam auftreten.
Die
Eine Syndrom ist eine Kombination von verschiedenen Krankheitszeichen, die gleichzeitig und gemeinsam auftreten.
Was ist tinnitus?
Das ist sehr ungewöhnliche Frage.
Singen?
Du sagst das ist eine ungewöhnliche Frage?
Das ist die Frage, Klingeln im Ohr.
Das ist ein guter Begriff.
Klinge...
Aber das ist auch in der Geräusche erlaubt.
Orun Zausen.
Er hat es in der Geräusche erlaubt.
Er hat zwei Begriffe gemacht.
Orun Zausen, Klinge im Oa.
Welche sind Sie?
Was ist die maximale Dosis von Ibuprofen?
2.400 mg.
Es gibt so eine Wurzeln.
Mit dieser Rezept-Rezept
kann man in der Apotheke Nua 400 mg Tablet kaufen.
Mit dieser Rezept-Rezept kann man in der Apotheke Nua 400 mg Tablet kaufen.
Was ist die Nebenwirkung von Ibuprofen?
Profen ist eine von nicht-theroidellen Antireumatiken.
Deswegen kann es zu Schleimhaut oder Magenschleimhaut-Störungen...
Oder Schädigung.
Schädigung.
Schädigung, ein bisschen mehr mit Algemein.
Crashback.
Schädigung, Verbrechen, Zoggbrenen, Zockbremnen und Verstopfung.
Drei Dinge.
Was ist das Häuschenкуhre, das die Allergik auslöst?
Was ist das Häuschenkuhre, das die Allergik auslöst?
Was ist...?
Was ist....
Polenallergie?
Ja, was ist das Häuschenkuhre, das die Allergik auslöst?
Das ist eine häufig beobachtene Allergiereaktion, besonders im Frühling wegen Polenen.
So genannte Polynose.
Das ist eine sehr beobachtende Allergiereaktion, die auf den flachenden Polen in der Luft aufgetreten wird.
Das ist eine Allergiereaktion, die auf den flachenden Polen in der Luft aufgetreten wird.
Was ist das Halswirbelsäule-Syndrom?
Die Nervenwürze sind betroffen oder die Nervenwürzen sind betroffen.
Dazu führen neurologische Symptome wie Kriben, Parasit, Hypothesie, Schwindel und auch Muskelkraftverlust.
Was ist das?
Schmerzen, Verschüpanung und weitere Beschwerden, die von der Halswirbelsäule ausgehen.
Warum hat der Patient ein Halswirbelsäule-Syndrom?
Wegen unergonomisches Arbeitsumfeld und unergonomischen Arbeitsbedingungen und fehlender Körperhaltung.
Das ist eine sehr beobachtende Allergiereaktion.
Die langsame Zeit im Büro und die Arbeitskontrolle.
Was ist Kriben?
Willst du einen Parasit?
Ich will das auch.
Ich habe eine Zensibilität.
Sogenante Parasite.
Kriben ist eine unangenehme Subjektive Enfindung.
Unangenehme.
Parasite, Hypothesie, Kriben.
Ich weiß, dass Parasite die beiden unterschieden sind.
Deswegen fragen wir die beiden Unge.
Warum?
Die beiden sind unangenehme Subjektive Enfindung.
Subjektive Hiss.
Die beiden sind unterschiedlich.
Eine Frage. Wie viele wirbelkörper hat ein Mensch?
Das ist eine Frage.
Ich lese die Frage.
Wie viele wirbelkörper hat ein Mensch?
7 Halswirbel, 12 Brustwirbel, 5 Lendenwirbel, 5 Kreuzbeine,
Kreuzbeine hat eine solche Bezeichnung.
Verschmortsenwirbel.
Das ist eine Art Verkauf.
Das ist die gleiche Frage.
In der Schiteisbeine sind 4 Verschmortsenwirbel.
Ich kann das nicht verstehen.
Wie können wir das beobachten?
Ein Arab-Kinder sagte mir, dass ich in der Simulation so verabschiedet bin.
Er sagte, ich bin ein Fag machen.
Ich dachte, das würde nicht so sein.
Er sagte, ich habe ihn nicht so gut beobachtet.
Er sagte, ich will das sagen.
Was haben wir gesagt? Ungetrent.
Meine Fragen sind vorbei. Entschuldigung, ich habe sie in der Hand.
Cetin, bist du bereit?
Was?
Die Frage kommt.
Aber es ist eine gute Frage.
Ich habe es in der Erfahrung gesehen.
Ich schaue, wo es kaputt ist.
Haben Sie gehört?
R-S-E
Was ist das?
Was haben Sie gehört?
Repetitive Schützreininjury.
Schützreininjury. In Englisch.
Aber das ist nicht Deutsch.
Was hast du gesagt?
Wegen wiederholten Bewegungen kann eine Beschwerden...
Die wiederholte Bewegung kann manchmal zu einem Beschwerden, zu einem Syndrom oder Krankheiten führen.
Vielleicht wegen der Arbeit oder im Sport, wie Tennis oder Golf oder im Büro mit Mausen zu arbeiten.
Was könnte die Ursache sein?
Wie gesagt, wegen wiederholten Bewegungen im Arbeit.
Zum Beispiel Handgeleken oder...
Der Zähnen.
Mikrotraum der Zähnen.
Okay, also die Ursache.
Du sagst das.
Du hast es gut erklärt.
Das ist ein Englischer Wort, aber wir werden es als Deutsch verstanden.
Ist es Deutsch?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Was ist Mausen?
Das ist das gleiche?
Nicht das gleiche.
Das RSI-Syndrom ist ein untypisches Überlastungssyndrom, das vor allem durch Schützreinigungen und Bewegungswiderholungen enthält.
Das ist allgemein, das ist alles.
Das ist Mausen, Golf...
Überlastung, Durchwiderholung.
Ich habe es dir in den HVC-Noten geschrieben.
Hast du die Noten von Benjamin an die Hand gelegt?
Ich habe sie an die Hand gelegt, aber ich werde die X, Y, Y-Kontrolle machen.
Ich werde die Heddy-Scheine auch an die Hand gelegt.
Ich habe die Heddy-Scheine an die Hand gelegt.
Das ist meine Hand.
Du hast nur deine Heddy-Scheine an die Hand gelegt.
Was ist Schützreinigungen?
Das ist für Impf-Rat oder Impf-Beratung in Deutschland verantwortlich.
Entwickelt Impfempfehlung für Deutschland.
Das ist nicht Infekung.
Das ist ein Institut für Robordkopf.
Aber ich weiß, dass das für Beratung ist.
Das ist ein Institut für Beratung.
Okay, dann erklärst du es so.
Impfempfehlung.
Das ist für die Erstellung von Impfempfehlung verantwortlich.
Das ist ein Individuelles Noten aus der Bevölkerung.
Das ist ein Bezirk.
Ich habe es schon erwähnt.
Immunisation von Bevölkerung heißt Heart Immunity.
Das heißt, dass es für die Gesundheit kommt.
Die Gesundheit ist das, was du gesagt hast.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau.
Ich werde auf diese Anleitungen noch mal sehen.
Hossam, kannst du mir die Tennisarm und Golfarm erzählen?
Wenn du müde bist, frage ich dich nochmals.
Das ist auch eine ...
Du kannst sie erzählen.
Ich kann sie erzählen.
Apikondylis lateralis, Apikondylis medialis betrophen
Es ist geschlossen, ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Ich habe es jetzt falsch gesagt.
Apikondylis lateralis und medialis sind die beiden.
Ich habe es wahrscheinlich falsch gesagt.
Du hast es richtig gesagt.
Die Interne haben ein Buch geschrieben.
Die Pharma-Kalorien.
Der Interne hat ein Buch von Nobel geschrieben.
Die Zentralisierungssysteme, Antipsychotik, Neuroleptik, Zawa, Zyngo,
die haben alles mit so nackten Sachen gedeiht.
Sie sagen etwas.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da bin.
Das ist kein Eponim.
Das ist so nackt.
İbrahim, ich habe dir das Potassium-Gespräch erzählt.
Er hat ein Buch verkauft.
Er hat Interne und so weiter.
Man kann sich so nackte Sachen in der Kopfkarte anbieten.
Das ist ein Nackt.
Ich habe dir das Potassium-Gespräch erzählt.
Nein, das ist nicht ein Potassium-Gespräch.
Das ist für uns vielleicht ein Test-Gespräch.
Das Buch sieht uns wahrscheinlich nicht gut aus.
Es ist eine neue Medikament-Kalik.
Aber es ist nicht wissenschaftlich.
Ich kann den Tennis-Arm lesen.
Du, du, du, du.
Das ist eine Schmerzhafte.
Und so ist es.
An der Außenseite des Ellenbogen.
Meist durch Überlastung.
Die Schmerzen beim Strecken.
Golfarm.
Hier sind inner, inner, inner, inner.
Ich lüge.
Innenseite des Ellenbogens.
Betrofen.
Schmerzen treaten beim Boygenauf.
Birin, die Golfarm bei Boygenauf.
Tennisarm.
Und Strecken.
Tennis, Strecken.
Das ist das, was wir tun.
Kann ich das mal versuchen?
Wir haben das Fertig-Leist gesagt.
Kann das sein?
Das ist ein Klassiker.
Wir haben die Bewegung.
Wenn ein Fertig-Leist mit einem Lateral ist.
Dann haben wir das Tennisarm.
So kann man eine Schmerzhafte und einen Fertig-Leist machen.
Die langen Wörter sind wahrscheinlich nicht in der Mitte.
So ein Sport, ein paar schlussige Wörter.
Vielleicht können wir die Wörter nicht sagen.
Das ist gut, Herr.
Aber das Drausen, das ist nicht in der Mitte.
Tennisarm, Drausen, das ist nicht in der Mitte.
Die wenden sich immer so.
Nein, ich sage das.
Das ist Begriff, das ist in Deutsch.
Epikondylitis, Lateralis.
Epykondylitis, Lateralis, Epikondylitis, Medialis.
Das ist nicht in der Mitte.
In welchem Organ kann ein
Karsinominstitut aufgetreten werden?
Servix lunga brustuose.
In welchem Organ kann ein
Karsinominstitut aufgetreten werden?
Ich habe das Wort falsch angeschrieben.
Ductus, das ist ein Slimehaut.
Ductus, die ganzen Kanzlerstunden.
Z.B. die Prostate.
Prostate hat keine Institution, ist das nicht hier?
Alle können es sein, wenn es eine Schleimhaut oder eine Kanalstruktur gibt.
Das kann in allen Kanzlerkonsummen passieren.
Und auch eine Glandulose ist vielleicht effizient.
Kannst du zwei Fählen der Bildung in der Kardiologie beantworten?
Ich kann es Ibrahim-Holger beantworten.
Was ist Fählen der Bildung?
Ich frage Ibrahim-Holger Kammdur, dann werde ich es erklären.